this week's deadly bombing at the
Manchester Arena in England is raising
concerns about the current therapy
terror threat in the United States
national security is this morning's
topic in our series issues that matter
Secretary of Homeland Security John
Kelly gave a sobering update on
terrorism yesterday to Congress as
horrible as Manchester was my
expectation is we're going to see a lot
more of that kind of attack we saw an
Indonesian secretary also said his
department is watching a number of very
sophisticated advanced threats secretary
Kelly's with us in studio 57 we're
pleased to have a welcome thanks charlie
looking at the terrible tragedy in
Manchester you expect an attempt of that
nature
here in America well the reality is
they're attempting everything all the
time you know the very very good news
charlie is that we have tremendous
professionals fighting the away game for
us protecting us that's Department of
Defense CIA NSA working with great
partners around the world then DHS of
course doing the home game fight thus
far we've been successful in keeping in
keeping an attack from overseas coming
here but we have some vulnerabilities
now what are they well we're a free and
open society that's the greatest news I
think in the world to people like us at
the same time it is a vulnerability
where restricted them should be on
collecting too much data or in private
citizens I mean you have to you have to
commit a crime in this country in our
country to to get the get to police
after you so it is a vulnerability but
it's one we work with and so long as we
are vigilant and we are day in and day
out and as I say there's tens of
thousands of great Americans or protect
us every day in uniform law enforcement
FBI CIA dia homeland security we have to
be perfect and we have been thus far
since 9/11 and intelligence is always
critical huge huge telogen sharing huge
on on that note when we talk about soft
targets concert halls airports stadiums
is DHS recommending that American
citizens do anything specific we have no
specific credible threat
now that doesn't mean it couldn't happen
but we have no specific credible threat
but the old expression you know if you
see something say something
report report report to your local law
enforcement if something seems out of
whack whether it's a you know an
unattended package or just some people
acting strangely I mean it's we don't
have to be paranoid we don't have to be
you know crazy about this but we have to
every citizen is in my view a
intelligence collector not in the sense
of monitoring their aura or watching
people too closely but just if you see
something say something and as we
increase our security our intelligence
our defenses are they also those who
wish us harm getting more sophisticated
more talented and better at it yes you
know the range of threats that we watch
from the very very sophisticated threat
of trying to take an airplane down in
flight to a a threat like we saw in
Manchester which is quite sophisticated
bomb building in all the rest of it to
the very very unsophisticated running
people down on Westminster Bridge or
attacking people with a machete or
something like that but just consider
the fact we've had four terrorist
attacks in four different places in the
last week Manchester Egypt the
Philippines in Indonesia
the very very good news is it hasn't
happened here and again we're
forward-leaning
within our laws but we're
forward-leaning but concerns as it
concerns Manchester the British
intelligence services expressed their
dismay about leaks that came from the
United States the president has ordered
a review to find out where those leaks
are coming from are you at all concerned
about leaks from the Department of
Homeland Security I'm not but you can
you know no one's perfect
no organization is perfect I would tell
you that right after the bombing
happened I called my counterpart who I
have got a great relationship in the UK
offered our condolences for the terrible
attack and she brought the issue up with
me she is absolute right to be furious
about these leaks and I think exactly
the right thing for the President to do
is to get the investigators on it find
out who it is they're totally
unacceptable particular
when it comes to classified information
tsa is anticipating a large number of
travels this summer period
what's the most important thing you can
say to those travelers as they travel
this summer the most important thing
would simply be to just bear with the
process you know in the last several
months my TSA people are just phenomenal
people you know you see the person that
gives you a little bit of inconvenience
while you go through the gate by the way
they're protecting your lives but you
see that but it's a very very large deep
organization tremendous professionals
from what you see at the airport to
command centers to actually scientific
research in terms of trying to make the
travel process a safer go on the TSA
website register and have a check number
from TSA the average weight in America
right now generally speaking going into
the travel season for a person to go
through the checkpoint I think it's in
excess of 90 percent of people wait for
five minutes or less and a very very
small number obviously then have but all
weights are under 30 minutes we've heard
talks we've heard reports that DHS is in
talks with European officials to expand
the laptop ban on airplanes to flights
coming from Europe can you tell us more
about that I have there's several very
sophisticated threats they're real
they're scary but we've got we believe
enough of an understanding of them to be
able to deal with them I'm in pretty
much constant contact with my
counterparts in Canada and in Europe I
sent a team recently to Europe to meet
with the EU in all of the
representatives of Europe this is the
not only the airline industry people but
again my counterparts ministers sub
ministers that kind of thing
we are developing new protocols we may
still ban not ban we may still initiate
that protocol where large electronic
devices are put in the cargo hold of
aircraft there's a lot of safety issues
that we're working out but we may expand
right now it's that time line for that
no dr. Kelly secretary Kelly thank you
for coming here
make sure happy Memorial Day and to you
as well
he was all over